Hi I'm Leslie, I'm a blogger and if you
want to know how to get this glittery
festival look - keep watching. To start
I prime my face with the Benefit Pore
Professional Pearl Primer, I apply this
with my fingers all over my face and rub
in. For foundation I like the NARS
Natural Radiant Longwear Foundation. I'm
dotting this all over my face before
blending in with my fingertips. I then
go in with a little concealer, I'm using
Too Faced Born This Way Naturally
Radiant Concealer and I dab this over
any areas I want to brighten.
I'm keeping my brows soft and natural so
for this I love the Estee Lauder
Brow Now Volumizing Brow Tint. I brush
this over my brow starting at the edge
and working my way out following the
natural shape of my brows. To add a
little warmth on the cheeks I'm using
the Smashbox Cali Contour Palette. I
apply a matte bronzer shade first with
a bronzing brush and then I add the
matte blush shade to add some colour.
To highlight, I love the NARS Iluminator
in Copacabana.This is one of my favourite
highlights and I love to use this on the
tops of my cheekbones and my eyebrow
bone. Now for the fun part, I'm using NYX
glitter in Bronze Dubai and Lumi Light.
So one of my hacks for getting the
glitter to stick is using a lip balm I'm
using the Lanolips 101 Ointment Multibalm. So you can
either apply this with a brush or use
your finger to dab. Then I go in with the
glitter. I love mixing two shades
together to give it more dimension. To
finish this glittery eye I love adding
stars to really make this look pop. Don't
forget to add definition. I'm using the
Smashbox Super Fan fanned out mascara.
Finally to finish this festival look I'm
using Too Faced Melted Chocolate on my
lips. I love the shimmer and it smells
amazing. For more videos like this
subscribe to GLAMOUR UK's YouTube
channel.